So let's go to Shimon Prokupecz,
who is outside the courthouse in Miami.
Give us
the latest on the ground
view of the security situation.
Shimon, what are you seeing
So, Jake, we're standing on the corner
where everyone here
from law enforcement
to some of the supporters
have now gathered
as they get ready
for their former president
to drive this way
and enter the courthouse.
We expect this to happen at any minute.
As you can see now,
some of the highway patrol,
the motorcycles are here.
This was not here earlier.
And then on the other side,
we have the street
clothes as well as everyone here
at this point is just waiting.
I'm trying to look and see
if I can see the motorcade
at some point
drive up this block to see
these are coming up this block.
And, Jake,
what's going to happen is,
is he's going to make a left here
and head right into the courthouse here.
You could see in our shot here,
there are some officers,
Secret Service agents and U.S. Marshals.
That is where we believe
he's going to drive down
and into that building
where he will begin
the process of being placed under arrest
and then the arraignment.
But at any point now,
we should see him take a drive by.
We can hear the sirens as they are
approaching here
and about to make this turn here.
Where law enforcement,
as you can see behind
me, Jake, has shut the street down.
And we see
some of the law enforcement here.
Now, Jake, driving in.
You could see this and there is
one of the here is the motorcade.
Now, Jake
and Shimon,
describe the crowd as you can.
As you can discern their mood
and their actions,
from our view, thousands of miles away.
It looks like a relatively peaceful
crowd The second black SUV.
Yeah, it is a relative.
It's been peaceful, Jake. You're right.
Absolutely right.
It's a peaceful crowd.
What we just saw.
So you can see some of the cameras there.
And the police are pushing away
somebody who is dressed
kind of like
as a cartoon prisoner with a sign
that says lock him up.
But he got on the street,
I think was the issue there
and the police came and pushed him aside,
although it didn't look like
a tremendously violent confrontation.
Sorry. Go ahead.
Yeah, because what's happened
here is this
people have been able
to just stand here, right.
We've been talking about the barricades.
They're not being any of those
metal barricades to people
to keep people
from running into the street.
Well, that's exactly what happened here.
People can run freely.
All we have,
really, are the officers
who are standing around
trying to keep people back.
But now the former president,
Donald Trump,
is inside the federal building
where he will be placed
under arrest, Jake,
where he will be taken in process,
as we've been talking about,
the fingerprint team,
the other
things that they do in the process.
And so now we await
for his appearance, Jake.
All right.
Shimon Prokupecz, thank you so much.
And as we watch these images, let's chat
with my panel here and Dana Bash.
I mean,
we should just take a moment here.
This is a historic day
and not in the good sense.
This is the second time
a former president,
Donald John Trump, has been arrested
and arraigned
the first time it's on federal charges.
All of the swirling politics,
all of the back and forth
that defend him, not defend him.
You're exactly right.
That is all
maybe for this moment
important to put aside and to mark
the history
that this is something
that they will be learning
about in history books
for a very, very long time forever.
And as you said. And not in a good way.
Not in a good way. Jamie Gangel.
Truly an ugly, ugly moment
given the seriousness of the offenses
that Donald Trump
is accused of committing.
The gravity of the charges, the evidence
arraigned,
the evidence in the indictment,
the evidence late against him.
And we talk to Republicans
who are not in the thrall of MAGA.
The former attorney general, Bill Barr,
who's very supportive of Trump
in many in under many accusations,
but not in this one.
Talking about the gravity
of these allegations.
Bill Barr saying
if half of what's in
the indictment is true,
it's horrible for Donald Trump.
Obviously a Republican
presidential rival,
but Chris Christie,
also a former ally of Trump
and a former U.S.
attorney
talking about how Donald Trump
brought this all on himself.
It is in a lot of ways.
I mean, it's
good to have a system of government
where no one is above the law.
In a lot of ways.
This is a very a sad moment
in American history.
Absolutely.
To quote Bill Barr,
he said,
if even half of it is true, he's toast.
That is someone who used to be
a loyal ally of Trump's.
You know, to this point, yes,
this is historic.
And to your point, sad
but I
think we also have to talk
about the big picture context.
This is not
the only thing
that Donald Trump is facing.
We had the charges in New York
that arrest an arraignment
two months ago.
We have
the special
counsel is also investigating him
for January six.
We, I think, expect
something to happen in Georgia.
The Fulton County
investigation may be in in August.
I was struck by two things today.
One is that
the surreal part
is we've done this before.
This is now oddly normal.
For us.
We have seen Donald Trump
taken in, arrested and and arraigned.
The other thing to me
was the difference in security
between Florida and New York.
In New York,
they locked down lower Manhattan.
You know,
luckily, the
crowds don't seem to be thousands
and seemed to be pretty well behaved.
But,
you know,
considering what we were hearing
last night,
the security scenes,
I mean, Andy, you can speak to
this is just doesn't
look like during much security.
Let me before it before we do that,
let me let me jump to John Miller
to talk to us right now
about what exactly is going on
inside that building, John.
So right now,
the president would be going
through the garage,
into the freight elevator.
He will be going with his Secret
Service detail,
which has him under protection.
But there's going to be a moment certain.
And it could be in that elevator
or it could be up in the U.S.
Marshal's office
where he's going to be approached
by the two FBI agents who are technically
arresting him on all these charges
in the name of the U.S. government.
And at that point,
the Secret Service takes a step back
because he is no longer
their protectee in a sense.
He is in the custody of the FBI
until such time a federal magistrate
at the end of this arraignment
and it's entirely likely
that they will say you're free to go.
And these are the following conditions,
which are probably just going to be
the have to return to court in between.
He will be he will be fingerprinted
with the electronic scan and those prints
will be run
against the records and entered in
We are told by Kaitlan Collins
that the procedure
of taking a DNA,
a DNA swab from his mouth with a Q-Tip,
which is the procedure
for all federal
arrestees, is going to be skipped.
In this case,
we're not sure why a photograph of him
will be uploaded into the system
It'll be an open source photograph.
They're not going to take a formal
mug shot
because there are plenty of pictures
I'm available to put in that record.
And then there'll be a brief holding time
for the magistrate to get ready.
And then he and his team
will go to that courtroom
where he'll be represented
by his defense lawyers
enter that plea
and the rest will unfold on the record.
What I described
is the part that nobody is going to see.
Also, no one will see in the courtroom
because there are no cameras allowed,
no recording devices, no telephones.
But there will be reporters
and sketch artists
and we will hear
after the hearing what occurred.